c'est la semaine européenne de l'énergie
durable deuxième du genre à cette
occasion nous sommes allés en navarre
sorte de laboratoire à la pointe des
énergies renouvelables 70 % de
l'électricité consommée dans cette
région vient des énergies solaire et
éolienne
pascal verre d'eau et tard nasri sont
nos envoyés spéciaux en espagne c'est le
dossier de ce soir fait c'est un rêve
qui a pris corps au sommet de cette
montagne
le rêve d'une autre forme d'énergie qui
n'était pas encore baptisé renouvelables
premier atout le vent et le site
nous sommes sur le chemin de saint
jacques de compostelle où se trouve le
premier parc éolien construit en navarre
il est entré en fonction en décembre
1994 dans les gradins depuis cette date
les éoliennes ont poussé comme des
champignons
mais surtout la navarre a acquis un
savoir faire et l'expérience
incomparable recherche appliquée ici à
pampelune où ce technicien élabore une
carte des vents indispensable aux marins
et aux financiers le but de cette carte
des vents c'est de prévoir la production
horaire engendrée par un parc
d'éoliennes notre information et fiable
à plus de 80% par conséquent le
promoteur qui veut investir dans un parc
sera de manière assez précise la
quantité d'énergie qu'il pourra vendre
ensuite au réseau car l'éolien c'est
aussi un business 10 milliards d'euros
d'investissements dans le renouvelable
pour cette entreprise de pointe présente
dans une douzaine de pays
ici on gère et on contrôle des éoliennes
implantées au canada et aux états unis
une partie des bénéfices est réinvesti
ensuite dans d'autres énergies non sur
ternoise et décadence ovale et à
l'afrique
notre priorité c'est l'éolien qui est
aujourd'hui l'énergie la plus rentable
mais nous voulons être présents dans
toutes les énergies propres
promouvoir les nouvelles technologies au
portugal par exemple nous construisons
la plus grande structure photovoltaïque
au monde dans une région sinistrée sur
le plan économique mais baigné de soleil
un secteur en plein essor comme cette
usine qui fabrique des pales d'hélices
et qui a déjà créé plus de 5000 emplois
dans la région
avec 70% de la consommation
d'électricité issue des renouvelables la
navarre fait figure de laboratoire
européen
elle produit aujourd'hui près de 1000
mégawatts soit l'équivalent d'une petite
centrale nucléaire